wie weit wollen wir eigentlich noch gene
die klimaaktivisten das fragen sich
viele deutsche jetzt nach diesen szenen
fußball bundesliga bayern gegen gladbach
und an der viertelstunde rennen diese
vier typen auf dem platz wollen sich an
den pfosten binden diese vollpfosten
werden sagen sie dann teilweise eben
auch gemacht thomas müller hat ein
bisschen aufgeräumt aber die frage
bleibt doch mensch jetzt
fußball-bundesliga vorher die ganzen
kunstwerke dort in dresden straßen
sowieso lässt die politik diese
klimaaktivisten viel zu viel gewähren
braucht es da viel härtere strafen
klimachaos immer wieder diese klima co
beim 1 1 gegen bayern und gladbach im
topspiel am samstag stürmten in der 17
minute klima idioten aufs feld und
versuchten sich an den beiden pfosten
des borussia torres fest zu binden auf
ihren t shirts steht stoppt den fossilen
wahnsinn nun gut der wahnsinn der klima
chaoten wurde dann auch relativ schnell
gestoppt die beiden männer wollten sich
mit kabelbindern fest binden konnten
diese jedoch nicht richtig bedienen also
schließen und wurden kurzerhand von
ordnern aus dem stadion getragen aber es
ist ja auch nicht das erste mal dass
solche protestaktionen in stadien schief
laufen diese ist noch vielen stadion
besuchern in erinnerung übrigens auch in
münchen im juni letzten jahres sturz ein
greenpeace paraglider mit seinem schirm
ab und verletzte zwei menschen um
möglichst viel aufmerksamkeit für ihre
forderung zu bekommen denken sich die
klima chaoten immer neue aktionen aus
erst am donnerstag hatten sich zwei
aktivisten an ein kunstwerk in der
gemäldegalerie auf dem berliner
kulturforum geklebt auch hier in dresden
mussten teure gemälde leiden seit wochen
legen diese chaoten den verkehr lahm ja
sogar die formel 1 und die tour de
france kommen teils zum erliegen
wenn
und die linksextreme gruppierung die
letzte generation hat bereits weitere
aktionen angekündigt gut wenn diese dann
in zukunft auch so unvorbereitet wie am
samstag in der allianz arena sind dann
sind die aktion zumindest schnell wieder
vorbei
sprechen wir über dieses thema rainer
wendt bundesvorsitzender der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft ist schön dass
hebammen sind hell bent jetzt gibt diese
aktionen die nerven und dann gibt es
ganz viele solcher aktionen da setzt man
andere menschen der gefahr aus ja oder
man zerstörte dinge oder man legt seine
ganze straßen lahm des notarzt wagen
nicht mehr durchkommen ist der zeitpunkt
gekommen an dem wir wirklich härtere
strafen für die klima chaoten brauchen
zumindest ist der zeitpunkt gekommen
dass mir diese dinge so nennen als das
bezeichnet was sie sind nämlich
schwere straftaten die menschen wegen
gefährden und es sind auch keine
aktivisten klima idioten ist schon ein
treffen der ausdruck ich würde kriminell
extreme idioten hinzufügen denn dort
werden nicht nur menschenleben und
sachen von bedeutendem wert gefährdet
sondern es werden schwere und schwerste
straftaten begangen und darauf müssen
alle reagieren übrigens allen voran die
politik die diese art von straftaten
immer wieder als aktionismus verharmlost
hat und auch niemals eine klare grenze
gezogen habe zwischen gewalt gegen
personen und gewalt gegen sachen
rechtsbruch bleibt rechts bauch und das
muss man dann auch ja sogar im gegenteil
da gibt ja hier in berlin noch einige
politiker selbst
bezirksbürgermeister die sich noch
verbünden die da teilweise mit auf der
straße sind und er sich offenbar am
liebsten selber mit festkleben würden
herr wendt braucht man machtwort des
kanzlers oder der innenministerin
ich habe da wenig illusionen
auch kanzler und innenministerin haben
ja ihre jungsozialisten die grünen sind
sich selbst genug und die linken machen
alles fleißig mit diese dinge immer
harmlos der kanzler kommt darauf
reagieren zu können noch auf die
bundesinnenminister in höhen die
jungsozialisten als allerletztes und zum
schluss verbünden sie sich hat dann ja
auch alle und reagieren mit den linken
gemeinsam wie beispielsweise in berlin
und das ist genau das falsche signal das
bürgerliche rechts treue kräfte im land
werden als
aus der zeit gefallen dargestellt und
diejenigen die schwerste straftaten
bedient als aktivisten heroisiert das
ist der falsche weg politik und von den
grünen und den linken und den
sozialdemokraten er warte ich jetzt
endlich dass sie diese form von
kriminalität da auch genauso beginnen
und bis in die ortsvereine hinein
verurteilt ganz klare ansage von rainer
wendt
[Musik]